you never know where the next great idea
will come from the one good place to
look was an event underway in San
Francisco this week the TechCrunch
Disrupt conference is where scores of
innovators share their startup ideas and
some had a very serious purpose such as
saving lives during and after natural
disasters amidst this smorgasbord of
high-tech innovation known as TechCrunch
Disrupt San Francisco this week
inventors seek investors who will
bankroll their big ideas for promotion
actor Will Smith dropped 10 grand on
Wednesday after hearing about siendo
dot-com a startup that claims will help
companies with their social media
presence and I participate in a
hackathon but Pedro Cruz's drone Aid
already had the backing of big blue aka
IBM long before this conference his
program uses a drone an on-board
computer and satellite readouts to relay
symbols of distress to emergency
responders the inspiration behind it all
Pedro's 82 year old grandmother one of
thousands of Puerto Ricans in the path
of hurricane Maria
back in 2017 stranded in her home
without a phone or assurances from first
responders Pedro set out to find her
himself when we tried to cross the roads
there was cables down it was flooded
dangerous yeah it was very dangerous so
I took my drum with me and we couldn't
reach her but I was at the flyer around
her house and about in a few seconds she
looked at she saw she heard the drone
sigh and wave only his drone spotted her
but it also gleaned desperate messages
from others in need on a basketball
court and on roads calls for help in
painted lettering assurances even of
survival so I thought of a way where we
could have drones automatically fire in
an area right after a disaster
automatically collect those messages and
then report that to first responders and
plug those results on a map and plot
those results on a map he took the idea
to a hackathon competition a year after
Maria hit well you're discovering is a
great idea picking from anywhere that's
right
Daniel crook is the chief technology
officer for call for code an
international competition sponsored by
IBM to use tech to solve some of the
world's greatest challenges so we find a
lot of innovation coming from all over
and solutions built for something local
like what Pedro Cruz is built with
droney
is something that can be transferred
elsewhere in the world Pedro was one of
more than a hundred and eighty thousand
coders from a hundred and sixty five
countries who competed last year he now
works for IBM I mean when you look
around you're like oh my god I'm here
because I wanted to help my grandmother
yeah so this all started because I
showed up I showed up at a hackathon and
at that hackathon I create a solution
thinking of her thinking of the
situation that Puerto Ricans had but
also other people around the world who
are suffering natural disasters mother
necessity I tell you I learned something
here have you guys heard of open source
technology software something I never
heard essentially there is no patent to
this he has offered it to the world
he's hoping others will add to it and
and make it even better but this idea of
open sourcing is part of this new
generation and it's something that
really incorporates sharing of ideas
which i think is really cool creating in
collaborating together yeah three brains
are better than one
now I have gonna be better than one what
a great idea and it seems so simple from
the start
yeah good stuff